A movie that we watch in the TV shows us from 25 to about 60 images per second.
In computer graphics these images are
referred to as frames.
A slow-motion camera can capture up to the order of thousands of frames per second
providing breathtaking footage like
this. One can quickly discover the beauty
of even the most ordinary, mundane
moments of nature.
But, if you think this is slow motion
then take a look at this.
Computer graphics researchers have been working
on a system that is able to capture one
trillion frames per second.
How much is that exactly? Well, it means
that if every single person who lives on
Earth would be able to help us, then
every single one of us would have to
take about 140 photographs in one second. And we would then need to add all of
these photographs up to obtain only one
second of footage.
What is all this good for? Well, for example, capturing light as an electromagnetic
wave as it hits and travels along
objects in space like the wall that you see here.
Physicists use to say that there is a
really really short instance of time
when you stand in front of the mirror.
You look at it and there is no mirror
image in. It it is completely black.
What is this wizardry and how is this
possible? Since Einstein, we know that
the speed of light is finite.
It is not instantaneous. It takes time to
travel from the light source, hit the
mirror, and end up hitting your eye for
you to see your mirror reflection.
Researchers at MIT and the
University of Zaragoza have captured this very moment.
Take a look. It is an enlightening
experience.
The paper is available in the
description box and it's a really
enjoyable read. A sizable portion of it
is understandable for everyone,
even without mathematical knowledge. All you need is just a little imagination
Thanks for watching and I'll see you
next week!